here's a fact we need cleaner cars if we
want to slow down climate change cars
and trucks produce almost a quarter of
the greenhouse gas emissions in the US
worldwide they produce almost 17 percent
but the road to cleaner cars might be
longer and dirtier than we think here's
the situation
back in the 90s Europe oast more
efficient diesel cars with tax
incentives the problem is while diesel
engines produce less co2 than petrol or
gas-powered engines they emit a number
of harmful pollutants including nitrogen
dioxide which creates smog and acid rain
also back in the 90s but on the other
side of the Atlantic the u.s. threw one
and a half billion dollars at a
struggling auto industry to develop a
car that could drive 80 miles per gallon
but that never materialized
20 years later the average fuel economy
of new vehicles sold in the u.s. is just
over 25 miles per gallon and companies
like Tesla Chevy and Nissan had been
betting on electric cars why are we
making electric cars why does it matter
it's because it's very important to
accelerate the transition to sustainable
transport Tesla boss Elon Musk says
electric cars are cleaner than their gas
chugging counterparts and are the
fastest way to reduce emissions from the
transportation sector but some question
of electric cars are actually all that
clean pointing out they often charge
their batteries using electricity that
comes from coal burning plants that is
changing as electric grids get greener
and increased power demand from electric
cars could help drive investments in
clean energy but transforming the
world's power grids will take decades
now here is the argument critics say
initiatives like Europe's diesel push
and the u.s. super car show the danger
of governments trying to pick winning
technologies but advocates of
alternative fuel cars point to
California or a mix of tightening
emission standards for manufacturers and
rebates for consumers encourage
investment in a range of newer
technologies the real wild card is China
in India sales of electric vehicles are
growing rapid
but not so in India and the huge demand
for new cars in both countries could
quickly cancel any real progress in the
quest for cleaner cars
you